Ladies. I'm so excited.
I want to dive deep right after that and get into it.
We're gonna play a little game.
This is a game called 'To Tell The Drewth'.
(bright upbeat music)
That's good.
Okay, Renee, you're up first.
Okay.
When you were in Hamilton, what would you
and Lin-Manuel Miranda say in sort of like the huddle
before you would go on
The prayer circle before Hamilton
he used to say two things.
One that I loved was it's like a restaurant
we're chefs, you know, it doesn't
matter what the reviews are.
Those people out there, if the meal isn't good
it's not good.
And the second thing he would say which I just
moved me so much was whatever you do, we're proud of you.
Isn't that Beautiful!
Whatever you do out there, I'm already proud of you.
I was just gonna say that's a good parenting.
Is that what a good parent's says?
(laughs loudly)
We will talk about that too.
Okay, Paula, you were a legendary writer
on Saturday night live.
I was lucky enough to get to be there in the years
that you were there as well.
You don't have to tell us who but,
was there a like a biggest tantrum
that you ever saw backstage at SNL?
The biggest tantrum I saw was actually for one
of our anniversary shows.
I remember someone getting so mad that rehearsal was
taking so long and they stormed down the hall out
of eight H storming stomping with a couple people nervously
behind them.
And like you know, cause they were
missing a Broadway show and they kept going,
thanks a lot NBC.
Thanks a lot SNL.
And they were in such a tantrum.
I mean, everyone was looking at him, storming out him.
it was a him.
By the end of the show I already
was going through it.
I'm like, okay.
(crowd speaking)
He just stormed out
and slammed any door could at everything.
And everyone kind of went all right
like did not throw a fit and scream at people,
you just didn't do it.
Well that is the oddest parlay into my question
for Sara, because I was wondering you know
you're starring on Broadway, you do these huge concerts.
You have to be live upfront, show up.
Have you ever had just something happening
in your personal life, a physical discomfort?
What do you?
You wanna know what happens
if I have to fart that's what's happening right?
(crowd laughs)
Or like you just broke
up with someone like farting and the heartbreak.
What do you do?
You know, I think in terms
of the emotional stuff, you try to, there's just not a world
in which you can't bring it with you somehow.
And I think in the best case scenario
you can sort of fold that
into the performance in some way that feels authentic.
(crowd laughs)
Now, folded in to the performance
Things happen.
You know, you spend a lot of time on that stage.
I love it.
Okay. Busy what did you guys talk
about in the car, in that iconic scene?
That was literally not only like,
I feel like it was on commercials for like three years.
Like this scene was, cause you're stuck
in those cars for a long for a long time.
Like hours and days.
So any juicy gossip
fun tidbits from the famous iconic scene?
Well, mostly this is true.
Mostly when they said cut,
Shawn and Marlon were asking us the lyrics
to a thousand miles
and we were asking them the lyrics to the rap song
and to help us learn that, except for Jennifer Carpenter
who came she's in the car with us.
And she came and knew the entire song.
That's what happens when you're prepared.
She was prepared
You get more screen time. You see.
Now, Paula, I want to ask you, you met your wife
on Twitter
(laughs loudly)
and I loved it because it gives it's so hopeful.
Like how did you guys meet?
What was it
about that tweet that changed the rest of your life?
Maybe you didn't know it then, but like, Oh my God
this is so helpful.
I'm so excited.
I'm gonna do a very fast version
of this cause it is a great, a great thing.
The way we found each other is she followed me on Twitter.
I followed her back.
I always thought she was cute
but I thought she was way younger
than she is, I'm sorry Janine.
(crowd laughs loudly)
But I just, would always see around there.
And she had funny tweets and I, you know
we'd kinder every so often make a little comment
on each other's stuff.
And then one day I was deeply, deeply
severely depressed for a couple of years after divorce.
And I, told my dog sitter come over.
I'm gonna go to Joshua Tree with my
all my self-help books and wine and my crystals.
And I'm gonna go be by myself and ask the sky
and ask whoever's up there to please guide me.
Cause I am lost and I am deeply dark.
And so I went and I just checked my internet
like one time while I was there.
And I see this tweet
she put up that said I was so depressed.
I went to an Airbnb and I went to Joshua Tree.
(Drew gasp)
And so we started.
We knew we weren't going to see each other,
cause she was there to meet with somebody
for a work thing for one of the days.
And so I, we just like did that,
oh, look at this.
Are, do you have the same sunset view right now?
And we were like sending pictures and she's like, Oh
this is a dog I just saw.
And it was you know, typical, hot, lesbian fair.
(crowd laughs loudly)
And I was just like, you know, and we just kept talking
and talking and then we had a date the next week
and then we're married now for a year.
We've been together four years and we just got married.
(crowd cheering)
That's all I want I don't even have a girlfriend.
Just kidding
And Paula she's on our show
And she plays my ex-wife on Girls5eva.
(bright upbeat music)